No,
I don't think
since we're always much more complicated
than heather positioned,
facebook has done a brilliant job of
opening up to third party applications.
The issue isn't opening up its platform.
It's.
It has more to do with the individual's
user graph or social graph if you like,
which is who their friends are and when
you start doing that you run into these
privacy issues.
It's,
it's fine for me to decide.
You can find out all about me,
but as it fine for me to let you see who
all my friends are.
Maybe my friends don't want to be known
as my friends and so I shouldn't
necessarily have the right to reveal who
all my friends are.
One we'll use hypothetical example is
suppose I'm gay and suppose I'm
sensitive about that.
Know
in theory you shouldn't even be
sensitive about it because it's okay,
but some people are are they have to be
in their work or whatever,
and so if I have friends on my favorite
lesbian site,
they might not want me to open up my
social graph to all my friends on
facebook who could then say,
oh,
well that's interesting.
Esther has all these gay friends so
people get outed by their association
with me.
I mean it's,
it's a very complicated thing and I may
have my own reasons for not wanting
certain people to know certain things.
Like I may have
an ex boyfriend that I don't want to see
certain things about my new boyfriend
because rather than hating him and
wanting to make him jealous,
I still like him or you know,
it's just.
Or I may not want my mother to see
pictures of my stepmother.
Not Because of privacy,
but because of a certain delicacy.
Again,
I have my own reasons for wanting to
control this information.
It's not quote privacy,
but it's not something where I want even
my friends to plaster my information all
over the place.
So it's,
it's a complicated thing.
What facebook did so brilliantly was
they said,
we're,
we're not so much a single community.
They're way too large to be a community.
We are a platform on which people can
build communities,
but no,
we don't want to be a public utility.
We want to be a
proprietary.
Ultimately moneymaking utility and
negotiating those shows is really tough
and facebook hasn't done it without a
bunch of errors on the way,
but there are basic.
This is what,
yeah,
who should have done and failed to do.
Facebook is doing it.
They're pioneering and they're,
they're,
they're learning by trial and error and
every little errors being
viciously.
It's a million small mistakes.
I don't know.
I mean the,
the,
the boats were all going by facebook
jumped on and one of them and then
turned it into a much bigger boat.